(crowd cheering and clapping)
- So, last time you were here,
you were very pregnant.
- I was plus one.
- Yes.
- Yeah. And felt a little
alone walking out this time.
- I know, a little empty.
No. How are you sleeping? Two now, right?
- My baby just turned two a few weeks ago.
- Yeah.
(crowd clapping)
- Thank you. We made it.
- People said terrible twos,
but threenager is a real thing.
- That's what I've heard.
- Yeah.
- But then again, he
turned two, two weeks ago
and as I was leaving to come here
he was just like on
the floor, just crying.
And I was like-
- Why are you leaving me?
- I have to go see Kelly
Clarkson. I'll be back.
- I know they lay it on sometimes, like,
why are you leaving me?
- Yes. Totally like blocking
the threshold of the door.
It's quite traumatic.
- That means that you were loved.
- Yeah.
- He misses you. That's nice too.
- He's an angel. No, it's the best.
I mean, being a mom's he best.
- But what have you learned about yourself
like since becoming a mom?
- I mean, don't be too
rigid in your plans.
(laughing)
Because anytime I try to hold
on to like a timing schedule-
- Nope.
- It just, it doesn't work.
So I try to be, you
know, go with the flow.
- Yeah.
- You know, take everything as it comes.
I try to, you know, get
my sleep where I can.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- When I was younger my
mom would always be like,
Emma I just need to sit down.
And I'd be like, I don't get it.
And now I'm the one being
like, I just have to sit down.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like I totally get
the sitting down thing.
- One hundred percent. I
always have to plan my schedule
like an hour in advance so
we actually make it on time.
- Yes. That's also a hundred percent.
Have to leave an hour padding,
if you make it at all.
- Yeah. Right.
(laughing)
- Sometimes I'm literally like,
I'm just not gonna make it.
- [Kelly] It's just not happening.
- And I don't even come up with an excuse.
I'm like, we're just not
getting out of the house.
- We're just not coming is the thing.
It happens.
So are you sleeping again?
- I'm sleeping again, but you know,
I wasn't obviously for the first year.
- No. Yeah.
- And I just, all I
care about now is sleep
and making my sleep the
most luxurious possible.
So I'm like,
- [Kelly] Yes.
- eye mask, bath, face mask.
- Yes.
- Like everything I can
do to just cocoon myself
to get the best four hours sleep.
- I know. I'd like to get a solid five in.
No, it's so funny because
when I was younger
I always felt like, I mean
I can go like nonstop.
- Oh yeah.
- I wouldn't sleep for days.
- No. You sleep, you go out,
you work, you don't care.
And now I'm like, I only got eight hours.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'm like, I am fraying.
- I will be a human you hate
if I get less than seven hours.
- Yes. Totally, a hundred percent.
- Yeah. It will go downhill very fast.
So, I heard though
that you've always had
kind of sleep issues.
My son has, he's sleepwalks.
Did you sleepwalk?
- You know what, I did.
I had a little bit of sleepwalking.
- Yeah. That's scary.
- Well, I hope it's not like hereditary
because my mom slept walk.
Slept walk? Sleepwalked?
- [Kelly] Slept Walk. I don't really know.
- [Emma] Oh there's my mom.
We were both sleepwalkers. How about that?
I'll, redirect that.
- [Kelly] There you go.
- We were both sleepwalkers
and actually one time
I was sleepwalking and
she was sleepwalking
and we actually ran into each other.
And we were both so freaked out
and we realized we were both sleepwalking.
And I was just like, this can't be good.
Like are the doors
locked? What's happening?
- I know. It scares me.
Cause I had a friend and her brother,
he like walked out on the road
and he had no idea he was in the road.
So I'm like terrified. And
we have stairs in our house.
- [Emma] No.
- So I'm always like, oh my
god, don't find the stairs.
- No. Well I hope my
son's not a sleepwalker,
but I mean, he's two and we're lucky
he hasn't figured out he
can climb out of the crib.
Because he totally is capable.
- Yeah.
But he just hasn't which I
thought was very sweet of him.
- That's different with
boys and girls too.
They're a little more behind.
- Yeah. He's just, he's
happy to, you know,
just stay in the crib
which is nice for now.
But I just know he's
gonna climb out one day
and I just hope he doesn't
sleep walk on top of that.
- Enjoy baby jail while you have it.
(laughing)
Because once they get out
you are like oh my god,
no, you can't draw on the walls
- No. Now he knows how to-
- For the fourth time.
- open door knobs and
turn on and off lights.
So it's like there's a
ghost in my house sometimes.
Like doors are open, lights are on,
I'm like, what happened?
I just turned all this off
this off and shut this.
- We had a power outage like,
I don't know, months ago.
And my son was so terrified about it.
So now to save power,
he goes around our house
and always turns off lights.
- Love that for him and for you.
- He's the most energy
efficient six year old
you've ever seen.
He turns off every light
because he is afraid that
the power won't come back on.
(crowd awing)
- I know. There's going
to be some therapy there
in the future. It's fine. It's fine.
I heard that you have a gadget though,
that you love that
helps you read at night.
So you don't have like just
a normal reading light?
- You know, I don't.
- [Kelly] Okay.
So I've gone through
every book light in town.
And none of them, you know,
they like fall off the page.
They're not bright enough.
- You keep having to
switch it off the page
and then it's not as
bright on the other page.
- Nope. It's not.
And also I'm always traveling so I'm like,
how can I read in the car?
And ever since I was a kid, I mean,
I don't know about you guys or you,
but when I was in the
backseat with my mom,
if you turn on that light, you were dead.
I don't know what it is about
parents where they're like,
if you touch that light, we will die.
So I never, I'm like, oh
God, I gotta get my own.
- We weren't allowed to
touch anything in the car.
- I know. What is that about?
- Yeah.
I don't have that same-
I realize now when I
drive and the light's on,
I'm like, it's fine.
Like, is it really that bad?
- Yeah. I think I just
innately became my mom
and I'm like don't touch the light.
- [Emma] Yeah.
- Because I'm afraid
they're gonna leave it on
and I'm not gonna see it.
- Okay. Well see that's logical.
- And it's gonna wear down
the battery or something.
My mom was like we
can't drive with that on
And I'm like
- Pure chaos.
- Totally. But no.
So I took it upon myself
to go another route with the book light.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And found this amazing light
that you wear around your head.
And so when you're looking at
the page, it's right there.
I brought you one so
you could actually see.
Thank you.
I think these are for hiking
and outdoor activities
but I use them for reading.
- I have one of these and I
play wolf pack with my children
in the backyard with
them when it's dark out.
- Okay.
I don't have this specific
brand. This is fancy.
Mine is more like, you
know, it costs $6 but um -
- And this one you can also
tilt it down to the page
might I add?
- Oh my gosh.
Wait. You just-
- Definitely not what this is for.
- Do you just sport this
in bed while you read?
- Yes. Look down. Look at your book.
- Well and look how amazingly
hot I look right now.
- Oh, and it's very sexy.
- Yeah. Probably on you Emma.
- If I could lift my arms in
this shirt, I'd put it on too.
- Oh, I'm gonna get killed by the way
from my makeup and hair.
But I'm willing to risk
our friendship over this.
So now that you're mama,
are you still getting a
chance to take vacations
like you used to? Because
it took me a while
to actually start doing that again.
- You know, well obviously not as much.
I get to also travel for work,
which doesn't count obviously.
- It does not count-
- And the baby comes with me.
- 'cause you're busy.
- But after Christmas,
I went to the snow for
the first time in years.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I skied and snowboarded.
- [Kelly] I love snowboarding, or I did.
- [Emma] You know, I'm mediocre at both.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Emma] So that's cool.
- [Kelly] My whole thing was like,
how you'd go up there and
people would race down.
First of all, I never looked
that cool on the slopes,
but people would always
race down, like friends,
and I'm like, it took us
forever to get up here.
I was like, I'm gonna coast down.
I would coast on the way like a grandma.
- Well I also thought I
was better than I was.
Like I was kind of talking a the big game.
I hadn't been up for a few
years. I'm like, I'm really good.
And then I realized I can
only snowboard on my heels
and like facing- I can't go on my toes.
- One hundred percent. 'Cause I'll bust.
- Yeah. I can't turn. No turning for me.
- Yeah, I do this.
- Yeah.
- And people turn and go backwards.
I'm like, why do we need to do that?
I wanna see everything.
Why would I do that?
- Yeah, totally.
- Yeah. Fancy footwork, but no.
- Getting off the chair lift,
I have to prepare for it
from the moment I get on
and usually I just dive forward
like I hope for the best.
- Yeah. It's embarrassing
watching me get off a ski lift.
(laughing)
I fall every time 'cause I freak out
and I'm like maybe I'll
just go and I'll crawl.
- It's just nerve wracking.
I just end up crawling cause I get nervous
'cause it's so fast. It's
really not that fast.
- I hadn't skied it since I was like 12
because my mom and I used to ski together.
But I had that little thing
that you put on the end of
your skis when you're a kid.
- I've never skied, only snowboarded.
- All right.
Well it keeps them
together. It's really dorky.
It's like not considered cool.
- It keeps it in like pie position.
- [Emma] Yeah.
- Okay.
- So my mom was like, you know,
it's time to get rid of that.
And I was like, I'm not.
And she's like, well,
then you should find
someone else to ski with.
So I started snowboarding.
So I finally got back on skis this year.
- Yeah.
And I was really feeling
myself on, you know,
the kids mountain, like
with the three year olds.
I was like, I got this, I got this.
I go up to the top of the other mountain.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Lost my ski.
The instructor was like,
what are you gonna walk down?
And I was like, oh great,
where do people do that?
(crowd laughing)
And he was like, no you can't.
- It was rhetorical.
- I was like, where's the
walking path? I would love to.
(laughing)
So I had to put that ski back on
and get down the hill
and it was not pretty.
- There should be a movie
made about people like us
going skiing and snow boring
because it is hysterical.
But it is fun when you're doing it.
- It is.
- Yeah. Some of it.
But anyway, so let's
talk about your new movie
because I've been very excited
to, because I watched it
and it was one of those movies
it's called, "Maybe I Do".
It's one of those movies
where I literally called like
four people after watching it
just downloading like everything.
I was like, I was afraid of
getting back in relationships
and then I was also like
relieved to not be in.
It was just, it's very thought
provoking and kind of scary.
- Yeah.
Like for your character and
then also for the parents.
It's, yeah. 'Cause love changes.
- Yeah. I mean, it's a story about love,
you know, and all different kinds of love.
I mean my character,
she is or thinks she is
like ready to get
married, ready to commit.
Her boyfriend is scared.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And then you meet their parents
and you kind of see why
they are the way they are.
And you see that one way
is not necessarily right
and one way is not necessarily wrong.
It's all heart and it's all feeling
and you just kind of wonder
like what's gonna happen
to all of these people's relationships
by the end of the movie.
- And even how they all-
- Connect.
I was like, no.
I was literally in my..
like watching it alone my
house going, there's no way.
Oh my God, it's happening.
- Well what makes me laugh
is that the the people,
you know, behaving badly in
love are not the young people,
I will say.
- I know that scared the
(beep) out of me, Emma.
I was like, are we doomed?
I was like, are we all gonna,
are people are gonna get bored or unhappy?
I was like, but then it was
interesting, I loved the-
even the dynamic of the older
relationships happening,
I loved how it showed like,
sometimes people, like
people always think,
oh, people cheat for certain reasons.
Sometimes it's just you wanna be heard
and you feel like you're
just not noticed anymore.
Or valued like any other
relationship, not valued.
And it was interesting.
- I feel like every character
in the movie has their reasons
and you start to unravel
that throughout the movie.
And it also just shows
that what I like is,
obviously you know,
people want romantic love.
We want romantic love
but there's all different kinds of love.
I mean, you know, like
love for your child,
love for your family,
love between friends
that feel like family.
And so, I don't know, I feel like
we're coming into a time where I feel like
there's so much different
kind of love people can,
you know, feel valued by.
It doesn't just have to be romantic.
- I had this whole conversation
with my girlfriends because I was like
one, I love that it showcased
the man's side of it too.
Like William H. Macy's character.
- Yeah.
- First of all, the level
of talent is insane.
- Oh, the cast-
It's like Diane Keaton,
it's like Susan Sarandon,
William H. Macy, Richard
Gere. It was everybody.
Oh and I love that you're doing a movie
with Luke as well because
y'all did Holiday.
- Luke Bracey. Yeah.
- Can y'all do the Meg
Ryan, Tom Hanks thing
and just do movies together?
- I know. I love him.
- Because I love y'all.
- Thank you. We have
the best time together.
- You have the best chemistry.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- When I read this script
and they were like,
Diane Keaton's doing it,
Susan Sarandon's doing it.
Richard Gear's doing it. William H. Macy.
I'm like, did you guys mean to call me?
I was like, wait,
- Was this the call?
- you want me to be in this?
And then actually Luke was
one of the last people cast
'cause they're like, who
should be your counterpart?
And I'm like, it has to be Luke.
- Oh my God.
- And I texted him, I was like,
if you say no, I am coming to find you
- [Kelly] And punch you.
- And he was like, no I won't, I won't.
I was like, I will be pissed.
- It's so good.
- Because there've been a couple
other movies that I'm like,
do this with me and we're
both like not quite right,
not quite right.
And this, I was like, if
you say not quite right
to Diane Keaton and Susan Sarandon,
- Yeah
- I'm done with you.
- Then you're wrong. Yeah.
No I just love when actors do that too.
I think fans like, we all love that.
- I love it.
- Yeah.
- I like always wanna see people
that have done movies together reunited.
- I know.
- It's Comforting.
- I turned it on, I was
like, this is Holiday.
I was like, wait, this is the same.
And I loved Holiday.
- Thank you.
- Way to go.
And remember I said this last time I think
but like there are very few movies
that come out around Christmas time
that I feel like really nail it
that you wanna watch every year.
- Thank you.
- And that is a good one.
- Thank you. I appreciate that.
But anyway, I love "Maybe I Do".
Everybody needs- I mean just
for therapy watch, Maybe I Do.